fat joe cole bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous sur rtl france on l'a vu en
les mesures de confinement ne font
visiblement pas à l'unanimité au liban
des affrontements lundi à tripoli ont
fait état de plus de 30 blessés dont six
hospitalisations selon la croix rouge
les autorités libanaises ont prolongé
jusqu'au 10 février un confinement
strict décrété
r au départ jusqu'au 25 janvier el fouad
zmokhol comment expliquer cette crise
sociale qui s'ajoute déjà une crise
sanitaire importante au liban écoutez
tout d'abord merci beaucoup de
m'accueillir à votre antenne c'est
toujours un plaisir et un honneur et
c'est très clair de dire à tout l'été ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui n'est pas
directement à cause du confinement
bécaud beaucoup plus à cause de la crise
sociale et économique qui sévit dans le
pays depuis je dirais une année ou plus
aujourd'hui il faut dire que toute la
population qui a perdu plus que 75% de
son pouvoir d'achat qui a perdu plus que
75 % de la valeur de ces dépôts s'il ya
encore des peaux qui sont bloqués dans
un système bancaire qui a investi dans
un état complètement déficitaire et on
vit en même temps une inflation qui a
dépassé les 300 ou 400 % à savoir
connaît un pays qui apportent 80% de ses
besoins de ses besoins primaires de ses
besoins humanitaires ou de ses besoins
en matières premières donc si nous
mettons aujourd'hui c'est deux points de
chute de 75% à pouvoir d'achat s'il y a
encore pouvoir d'achat est en même temps
une d'une hausse vertigineuse des prix
qui sont la plupart sur l'importation
qui sont payés en devises
en même temps nous savons que nous
sommes un pays aujourd'hui qui a suivi
une chute dramatique du son pib de 55
milliards à environ 20 milliards dont
une chute de plus que 65 % dont il n'y a
pas d'investissement n'y a pas de
création d'emplois et en même temps un
taux de chômage ya pas de chiffres
encore exact mais qu'elle est passée la
valeur des 38 à 40%
donc aujourd'hui si on met tout ça
aujourd'hui on comprend des lignes mans
une crise sociale dramatique jeudi sans
pareil unique depuis l'histoire du liban
qui n'est même pas comparable aux crises
qu'on a eu même durant les années les
pires de la guerre civile et en même
temps nous allons sur un confinement au
déconfinement l'idée n'est pas
directement s'il ya confinement ou pas
mais je dois dire malheureusement très
clairement qu'on n'a pas une stratégie
claire on n'a aucune stratégie sanitaire
qui a été
mon décrété avec aucun objectif à court
terme moyen terme au long terme ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui où ce qui a été mis en
tout cas par le gouvernement actuel
c'est confinement il ya mois de novembre
qui donnait aucune aucun résultat direct
et on peut d confinement qui dramatique
une très mauvaise décision suivie par an
confirmant donc finalement il faut dire
que c'est une population complètement
désemparée mais aussi qui n'a aucune
confiance sur ni la politique sociale ni
la politique économique et surtout pas
la politique sanitaire
vous avez parlé ou justement vous parlez
de confiance puisque le liban a recensé
jusqu'ici elle 282000 249 cas donc 2004
104 décès les hôpitaux sont saturés
comment lutter contre la propagation du
comité 900 froid c est les libanais et
cesser ses manifestations dans
l'impression qu'il ya un problème de
confiance envers les dirigeants
politiques
justement c'est exactement ce que je
disais qu aujourd'hui nous pouvons pas
aller sur une stratégie qui uniquement
sanitaires ou une stratégie qui
simplement relié sur un confinement au
déconfinement aujourd'hui quelle que
soit la stratégie et on n'a pas d'autre
solution que d'aller sur une confinement
doit être accompagnée doit être
accompagnée sur des mesures sociales
suppose spécialement pour aider les
spécifiquement la population avec nous
un taux de pauvreté qui a atteint plus
que 50 % de notre population
aujourd'hui prendre une décision
salutaire de la sorte sans vraiment
regarder on dans l'exemple on a les
industries qui sont fermés nous sommes
le seul pays au monde qui a fermé ses
d'industrie donc les industries mem ne
pourront plus survivre et même pas payé
les salaires donc aujourd'hui à mon avis
nous ne pouvons jamais s'en sortir sans
avoir vraiment un plan qui regroupe le
social l'économie la production et bien
sûr le sanitaire une population comme
vous dites si bien qu'ils n'aient pas
confiance qui n'est même pas confiance
la distribution du vaccin donc si même
vaccin qui va être offert est
subventionné par la banque mondiale on
n'est même pas sûr que ce vaccin va être
vraiment distribué de façon équitable à
une population
donc aujourd'hui c'est une crise
sanitaire économique et social et
surtout un problème de gestion parce que
malheureusement la gestion jusqu'à cet
instant n'a donné aucun vraiment aucun
résultat et toutes les décisions qui ont
été prises vont tes décisions qui n'ont
donné aucun résultat
donc vous avez une population qui vivait
sur le jour le jour à savoir qu'on a une
grande partie de la population active
qui travaillent sur ce qu'on appelle
emplois journaliers ou des emplois à
mi-temps donc cette population que s'ils
ne travaillent pas journalièrement n'a
pas de quoi manger et boire les mettre
en confinement durant quinze jours et
ensuite encore un mois sans aucun
support aucun sociales sanitaires
économiques malheureusement ne va faire
qu'aggraver la situation qui peut
vraiment aller hors de tout contrôle
malheureusement merci beaucoup pour tout
ces réponses fois deux mots coll je
rappelle que vous êtes président du
rassemblement des dirigeants et chefs
d'entreprise ibanez dans le hot